all right we'll uh go ahead and get
started so good morning everyone I'm
Joshua Ott I work in the Stanford
intelligence systems lab with Michael
and my research focuses on autonomous
exploration so that ranges from using
teams of robots or or any autonomous
system to explore some unknown
environment so that that can range from
uh Rover exploring a planetary surface
and looking at where to place its its
drill measurements to collect samples of
the surface or it can be teams of robots
so aerial and ground robots in a search
and rescue application trying to
coordinate and identify likely areas
where survivors will be and then going
and exploring those spaces so as you can
imagine that autonomous exploration
relies very heavily on optimization and
specifically what we're going to be
talking about today with surrogate
models and probabilistic surrogate
models
so I'm gonna pick up where we left off
on Thursday on surrogate models and then
we'll dive in to probabilistic surrogate
models
so if you recall from Thursday we were
talking about surrogate models and we
left off on model selection
so we had already fit our model to some
data and now we're trying to evaluate
the the quality of that model
so the data that we've used to fit it we
call that our training data and so
that's what that's what we use to create
our model based on whatever data we've
seen so far
once we once we have that model we want
to evaluate how good is our model doing
at data that we haven't yet seen so how
well is it generalizing to data outside
of what we've just trained on
so to do that we want to look at the
generalization error and this this is
giving us some Metric to say this
model's doing well this model is not
doing so well okay so that's that's what
we're sort of after here
so one way to to quantify the
generalization error is we can just
write it like this
is everyone able to see this board here
okay
so we can write the generalization error
as the expected
squared error so we'll we'll walk
through this here in a second
okay so we have the expectation over all
of the X's sampled from this space of
x's so this is all of the the possible
data we could see
and then we have this is the true
function value so this is what we're
interested in right we don't actually
know that function value so we have our
surrogate model here and this is what
our surrogate is telling us
so so this is a good definition to work
off of the only issue is that we don't
actually know this function value
so so it's a good definition to go with
but it doesn't really get us anywhere
right now because we don't we don't know
this to start with
so another thing that we can we can
think about is the training error right
so this is how well we do on the data
that we just trained on so very
similarly we can write that like this
where we have we've seen these M data
points so far
and then we're just looking at the error
on those specific data points
okay
so now this avoids this problem because
we know this we've gotten these data
points so we know the function
evaluation at those specific data points
and we're comparing that with what we
predicted
so that's our training error
and this is good it gives us gives us
some Metric the only issue now though is
that just because we have a good
training error does not necessarily mean
that it's a good model right we might do
really well fitting our our training
data but we might generalize terribly to
other data that we haven't seen so so
that's still an issue that we have
and and that's just the the main point
here is that models with low training
error they can still perform poorly on
on data that we haven't seen so far
so the the training error is not
necessarily a good indicator of our
generalization error
so one way to to get around this issue
is through using the holdout method
so this attempts to estimate our
generalization error by looking at uh we
partition our data our data set into a
training and test set okay so we have
some we have some entire data set that
we've collected and now we're just
saying we're going to take our eighty
percent of our data and we'll call that
our training data and we're going to
save the other 20 and we're not going to
use that for fitting and that's our test
data so so this is nice because we we
basically still get access to this we're
just saving saving it for later okay so
we take our our blue partition here our
training data and we train on that we
fit our our surrogate model and then
we're going to test on the the Red Data
here so an example of this that you can
see the Blue Points here
those were our our training samples so
we fit some model on on just those uh
data points
and then we saved the two the two red
points over there for our uh test data
and so now we can see well hey our model
does not do very good at predicting
those those data points over there so
this is sort of an indicator for us now
that okay our generalization error in
this case is not very good so that's
that's the uh the holdout method we're
just partitioning the data saving some
of it to to evaluate on
so cross validation extends this idea
we're still we're still partitioning the
data set it's just now instead of just
doing this train and test split we're
partitioning it into K different subsets
so in this case we have five subsets
here each one we we just randomly
partition up so one through five here
and then with those partitions we're
going to walk through this and so at at
each iteration that we're going through
we're going to use one of those
partitions as the holdout set okay so if
we if we walk through an example here
let's look at this so we've we've
partitioned our data up into these five
different partitions and now with the
first iteration we're going to go
through we're going to hold out just the
purple partition so just this D1
partition here we're holding that out
we're going to train our surrogate model
fit it on this data only and then we're
going to evaluate it just like we did in
the holdout method on our purple data
and that gives us one generalization
error estimate we then repeat this so
now we do it a second time this time we
train on everything except for the blue
partition and then we use that blue
partition to get another generalization
error estimate
so then we can just repeat that for the
rest of our partitions
and as we do that
we end up with now
uh K different estimates of our
generalization error and so with these
we can then just take the mean and
standard deviation of that
generalization error that we got
and that'll give us a new a new estimate
so some mean and sigma for our our
generalization error and you might be
saying well why why not just do the
holdout method why do we need
cross-validation
well the whole point of cross-validation
is that it makes us less susceptible to
how we partition our data so in the
holdout method you can think that maybe
in certain cases the way you partition
that data gives you a sort of biased
estimate of your generalization error
you might partition it in a way that you
get a really good generalization error
but if you had partitioned it you know
just a little bit differently that would
no longer be the case so cross
validation removes that that dependence
on the partitioning by doing this this
random partitioning into different
subsets
okay so any questions on uh cross
validation or holdout
yes
I guess
um if we go through and we do it
this way technically at some point we
have trained our
model on all the data right yeah yeah
that's a that's that's a good point um
so you will at each iteration you're
going to be eventually accessing all of
the data but the the sort of caveat here
is that at each iteration you're you're
not having access to the the entire data
set you're only getting access to that
specific partition at that iteration so
it's still hidden to you and then you
get that estimate so you might have
really bad generalization error on one
specific partition and that'll affect
your mean and standard deviation
here we have five different models which
one do we end up using yeah that's a
good question so this this doesn't tell
us specifically which model to select it
just gives us sort of uh an idea of
based on on the model type that we were
using so maybe we're just doing like a
linear fit it tells us that based on how
we partition that data with the linear
fit this is sort of what we can expect
our overall generalization error
estimate to be
all right so today we're going to be
talking about probabilistic surrogate
models and uh this is one of my favorite
areas in optimization and there's two
two main reasons for that the the first
is just that they're extremely versatile
so they're very widely applicable
whether you're looking at uh geoscience
modeling so looking at minerals in the
subsurface and sort of modeling how they
they change spatially or if you're
looking at Financial modeling they're
applicable there as well so anytime I
see that where where something is is
used in two very different fields that's
sort of like a flag in my head like hey
this is this is pretty cool this is
important so that's that's one of the
reasons that I I really like
probabilistic surrogate models it's just
the versatility the other reason is that
I think it's just a very powerful
concept of being able to quantify the
uncertainty in your prediction and I
think that sometimes gets overlooked in
in modeling applications because you
just have your model and it's doing a
reasonable job of predicting what you
haven't seen yet so you're saying okay
great that's that's awesome it's working
well but you're not you're not taking
that uncertainty quantification into
account so I think that idea is really
powerful so versatility an uncertainty
quantifications those are the reasons
why I really like probabilistic
surrogate models
and my hope for the lecture today is to
really give an intuitive understanding
first and then dive into the math in the
details so if you if you ever like lose
that intuition of why are we doing what
we're doing just feel free ask a
question and and we'll dive into that
so to start off with looking at today
we're going to be going probabilistic
surrogate models first what they are how
we use them and then we're going to be
looking at how can we use them for our
actual optimization uh purpose
so I want to start off first with just
sort of zooming out looking at the
everything we've seen so far all of the
different pieces of optimization and
where where this fits in
okay so so today we're focused here on
probabilistic surrogate models and
surrogate optimization and you can see
it's sort of it's its own sort of branch
in the the optimization topics that
we've covered so far so that's not to
say that everything on the top is not
important it's definitely important and
necessary to learn about especially if
you're going to be using this in your
work but the nice part is that
probabilistic surrogate models are sort
of their their own own Branch here so my
hope is that if this is the first
lecture you're attending all quarter and
you're just drop it in right here that
you would still be able to walk away
from this lecture with uh with a solid
understanding and probabilistic
surrogate models
so that's my hope
okay so let's get started here with just
a refresher of why we care about
surrogate models in the first place
so in in many different optimization
problems often the actual evaluation of
the function is pretty expensive so the
function that you're actually interested
in optimizing getting those uh sample
values are are expensive so for example
if you're doing some lengthy Hardware
fabrication process that requires you to
build uh the actual Hardware design
before you test it and get that function
evaluation that's going to be an
expensive process right it costs a lot
of time and it costs a lot of dollars to
go and actually get this this Hardware
prototype and then test it so a good
example of that is if you're building an
aircraft and you want to test it in a
wind tunnel you can't just go and build
thousands of different aircraft
prototypes before you actually ship one
right so you have to have some way to
predict how your your function will
evolve based on the limited samples that
you've seen so far
and lastly maybe another example here is
you're you're about to go train some new
deep neural network and it has you know
billions of parameters and it's going to
take weeks to months to train you want
to make sure that your hyper parameters
in there all are all tuned up nicely
before you go and spend five hundred
thousand dollars training that that
model so that's where the surrogate
model comes in it's a surrogate over the
actual function that we're interested in
and so because we're talking about
probabilistic surrogate models naturally
we would think that there's going to be
some probability involved here so we're
going to start just with a refresher of
our friend the gaussian distribution and
then and then we're going to work up
from there to the gaussian process
so I'm sure most of us have probably
seen the gaussian gaussian distribution
at one point this is just the the
expression here for it where we have
some mean and covariance Matrix and in
two Dimensions we get something that
looks like this where these are just the
the Contour plots of it so just taking
the slices here and just looking at the
effect that the covariance Matrix has so
as we as we change that covariance
Matrix it sort of changes the
orientation and shape of our of our
gaussian distribution here
and so if we want to look at you know
different different distributions with
the gaussian you know we can have two
jointly distributed random variables A
and B and we can represent them like
this and so that that allows us like any
distribution we can marginalize out one
of the one of the variables so for a
general uh probability distribution
marginalization is just integrating out
with respect to one of those those
variables so we can just integrate out
the effect of of B on our distribution
and that gives us just just a okay
and then lastly we have the conditional
distribution so this is just saying that
if we already know the value of B we can
say what is what is the distribution now
that we expect of a so it's a given B
and we just represent that here through
the gaussian update equations so it's
just uh we just have this given value of
B and then we're using that to condition
on that value of B and that will give us
a new gaussian distribution for our a
okay so that's just a refresher because
we're going to make use of these in
building up the gaussian process
okay so for gaussian processes we're
going to start with just a visual
example here to to build that that
intuition
so we're going to start and it might
seem a little weird at first but what
we're going to do here is we're just
going to plop our our gaussian
distribution in one dimension and we're
going to take it all along the the
y-axis here and we're just going to take
five samples from that
so we get our our five samples here and
we're just plotting the dimension on the
x-axis so here's just one dimension so
they're all just along that that First
Dimension there and then we're just
plotting the value of the samples along
the y-axis so that's all we've done
pretty simple
we can then take the same exact idea and
we're just going to build it up to
higher Dimensions so if we go to two
Dimensions now
we can have our our two-dimensional
distribution here we take again five
samples from that distribution and now
we're just gonna we're gonna plot the
dimensions along the x-axis here so we
take the first X1 Dimension and we plot
it there
and then we're going to repeat and we're
going to do the same thing for the
second dimension
so we take the the values of the from
the second dimension now and we're going
to plot them corresponding to the second
dimension so all we've done is just
taken those values and plotted X1 on the
x-axis and then X2 as well and their
sample value is on the y-axis
and then we're showing the covariance
Matrix here so you can see there's
nothing you know special about this
we're just showing that there's there's
some correlation here as well
all right so now we can just rinse and
repeat this up to higher Dimensions so
if we go to three dimensions you can see
we get some samples here and now we're
just again there's nothing special here
about this particular covariance Matrix
we're using all we're all we're trying
to illustrate is that there's just some
spatial correlation now so the value of
X1 is more closely related to the value
of X3
or sorry the value of X2 then X1 is to
X3 so the closer you are in dimension
the more uh relationship you have and so
you can just see that through the the
covariance terms uh in The Matrix
okay so we can
oh yeah question
maybe like the zero plus
row should be assumed what
yes that's true
uh well so yeah this 0.14 should be uh
0.61 this one here
is that what yeah yeah that's right
okay so we can continue that up so in
four dimensions we can do it in five six
we'll stop at eight for for this case so
we we have uh five samples now from an
eight dimensional gaussian where we've
just plotted them uh along the axis here
okay and so maybe these are starting to
look a little like uh samples from a
function to you and if they're not then
we'll we'll clarify it by going up even
higher Dimensions but uh that's exactly
the the intuition that we're trying to
get to here so if we if we take this up
to you know hundreds of Dimensions so
let's go now to like 200 Dimensions
we'll start getting these smooth looking
functions okay and we still have that
spatial uh correlation here and so all
we've done now we just have you know
lots of lots of samples now and we start
getting these smoother looking functions
and so that's exactly what a gaussian
process is it's just a distribution over
functions and all we're showing here is
five different samples from a gaussian
process okay so it's just distribution
over functions and all we're looking at
here are the samples uh from that that
function
okay so if we want to make this
connection a little a little clearer for
a multivariate gaussian
we have it defined by some mean and
covariance Matrix for a gaussian process
we're just defining it by some mean
function and some uh kernel function
so we can sort of write out the
structure that we're going to be working
with here
so we're just going to write it like
this
and we're going to break this down in
much more much more detail as we go but
just so we have a starting point here
we have our our y's these are the points
that we're going to be observing so our
function values
and we're saying that those are coming
from
a gaussian process which we're defining
by some mean function here
at the points that we've seen
so the m m different data points that
we've seen
and you can think about this this is
very similar to the mean Vector that we
have with a with a gaussian and then we
have some we have our covariance Matrix
as well
that might be cut off for you guys over
there
okay so we're just we're just writing it
out for all of our M different data
points
and we're just going to be making use of
this in the rest of what we're going to
be talking about here okay so all we
have we just have our our mean function
specified on on our data points and then
we're looking at the covariance Matrix
here is what we built but we use this
covariance function or this kernel
function here and so you might be asking
what what what is this what is this
covariance function well that's sort of
the modeling choice that you have but a
very common one and the one that we'll
be using a lot today is the squared
exponential kernel so how we write the
squared exponential kernel
this is squared here
okay so we have our our squared
exponential kernel it's just just the
negative exponential here and then we
have some length scale parameter so so
what this looks like if we were to draw
it out it looks something like this
where we sort of get this Decay okay and
so the length scale
controls how fast we're decaying there
all right so if we if we want to look at
some some examples of this
so this is just the same exact structure
that we've written and this is sort of
the definition that we'll be we'll be
working with here today
so if we look at some examples this is
using the squared exponential kernel and
we're we're just looking at we've
already seen the center one where L
equals one now we're just looking at how
how does that length scale change the
types of functions that we're getting so
as you can see that as we decrease the
length scale We Get Much More Jagged
sharply varying functions and as we
increase it we get more slowly smoother
varying functions
so that's that's sort of showing the
effect that the uh the kernel function
has on the type of function that we're
using and so just like that length scale
parameter you can see it has a pretty
significant impact on the types of
function uh function samples that we get
the kernel function itself that we're
choosing has has an even bigger impact
so if you want to look at you know we're
not just limited to the squared
exponential kernel we can use any any
number of these these are just examples
there's even more out there that you can
use
so you can see that the the choice here
makes a pretty pretty significant impact
on the types of functions you're going
to see and so that's where it becomes
your your modeling choice of which one
to use
and so I'll highlight two here we've
already seen the squared exponential
kernel uh the second one is the matern
kernel this one down here that you can
see and uh they're they're quite
different right the return is much more
Jagged and has those sharp sharp spikes
in it whereas the squared exponential is
a lot smoother
and so the the reason I'm highlighting
this is just one example is in the
geoscience modeling often when you're
looking at you know minerals in the
subsurface they're not just the smoothly
nice varying functions there's a lot of
noise there with these Jagged discon
discontinuities in the subsurface and so
a common thing to do is take a
combination of kernels so you can
represent the smooth nature of the the
spatial changes in the subsurface but
you can also represent that that sharper
varying uh term as well so that's just
sort of an example to highlight how you
can you you can take combinations of
these and it's it's really that that
modeling choice and you can use sort of
the previous things that we've talked
about like model selection to determine
how your your model is doing here
okay yeah
now what is the x-axis
yeah the the x-axis here these are just
uh basically like the X's that you've
seen so these are the X's that you've
seen not necessarily where exactly you
have data but just where you're querying
this this distribution at so we have
some distribution over our our y values
and so we're sampling the function
values which is the the y-axis and we're
sampling those function values at these
these X points
yeah previously when you had the uh I
guess like uh in your board is M the
number of variables or team number
examples yeah n is the number of data
points that we have so this well okay so
this m is our mean function but this m
is the the number of data points that we
have seen so far so we have M data
points that we've seen and we're going
to get into a little bit of that here in
a second so it should clarify that
it's going to be working
variables and
all this I believe like it was increased
increased size when you add in more
variables
right yes that's
children if you like the number of
variables
the number of bits yeah
it's the number of variables by the
local variables yeah so so I think the
example you're talking about was when we
were sort of building up the intuition
here yeah so this is this is slightly
different and we'll see it I think in
the next couple of slides
um but just for constructing so this is
on what we've seen so far these are the
the samples that we've seen
um so it's not an exact one-to-one map
to that intuition that we were building
up but I think you'll you'll see it uh
coming up here and if you don't then
then just ask again and we'll clarify
yeah we are using like this kernel
function for controlling each of the
elements in the equivalent Matrix so
which means that
um this kernel function is approximating
the covariance between two
but how like it doesn't make sense to me
that we have a covariance between two
data points like Health like what does
it mean to have a covariance between two
things yeah yeah that's a great question
so if we take the the spatial modeling
aspect of it right
um so say that we have
and actually we'll go with uh like phone
prices okay so say that you have we'll
go here
say that we have uh
we've got prices
here and we're looking at the number of
sales that we have for those phones so
maybe so far this is just based on like
historical data here that we have we've
we've sold the phone at these different
prices and then we have data on the
number of phones that we sold okay so
the uh the spatial relationship there is
just sort of telling us how much we
expect the function to change based on
how the the price relationship changes
so I think this one is is intuitive
right as we as we lower the price we
expect to sell more phones because the
price is is lower up to a certain point
right
so
uh what we can do here is we can we're
basically saying that uh the covariance
between let's say this price here we'll
call it I don't know P1 and this price
here P2
we're saying that those are going to be
more closely related than P1 and
whatever this point P3 here so that's
that's sort of the the intuition to have
is that the the closer the data points
are and that distance metric is another
thing that you can change but let's say
just in euclidean distance here the
closer those are the more related their
actual function value will be
okay so here I think we're just going to
build sort of a mental model picture of
what we're going to be working with so
the black line here is the true function
value so that's what we're actually
interested in that we can't directly
observe
well we can take we can take samples of
it but in this case it's a noisy sample
so that's why our black the black point
here is a noisy sample of that function
so all we have right now is one data
point and we can based on the squared
exponential kernel that's what we're
using here we can then uh make
predictions and then sample from it so
those those uh blue lines that you're
seeing those are the samples from the
function from the gaussian process
and so we can then condition on more
samples so as we take more measurements
we can make updates here so we can
update our our gaussian process
conditioned on these on these new
measurements and so as we go with only
three data points here again there's
they're noisy so we're maybe we have
some some sensor noise so we're not
exactly measuring the true function
value and that's why there's still
uncertainty around those points but we
can basically quantify the uncertainty
there that we have around our our true
function and so obviously this is you
know with three data points we're doing
quite a good job here a lot of real
world functions are not this smooth and
don't look like that but this is just to
sort of have that picture of how we're
we're progressing and adding more data
points to our gaussian process
and it's not just limited to one
Dimensions so you can take this up and
and do it in higher Dimensions as well
so yes
previous slide I I was curious what all
the different blue lines are
representing when you were showing the
different types of kernels yes it seemed
like the different lines were the models
you would get for each design variable
maybe that's wrong but I don't know if
we only have one or two design variables
here then what are all the blue lines
yeah great question so the blue lines
are the uh samples from our our gaussian
process so just like in a uh you know
like a one-dimensional gaussian you have
something you know you have your your
bell curve like that and you can take
you know five different samples from it
and get something like that that's
that's essentially all that we're doing
those are the blue lines here so we're
just sampling you know I think like 10
here or something
and
the gaussian processible yep yep yep so
yeah we're we're going along here we
have like 200 query points to make this
plot
um and at those at those query points is
where we're we're asking for the
function value
and we're gonna I think that's
the very next one here so we can do this
in two Dimensions as well and now I
think this this will hopefully make
things a little clearer so we've seen
just like the build up of this structure
but now we're gonna actually get to the
prediction here of how do we how do we
use these to make predictions about
about the function
okay so this example that we just saw
uh we're gonna sort of introduce the the
terminology here so the X's those are
the set of points where we have a known
value so these are our X's here that's
where we we have those known values that
we've measured
the wise
are the the points that we've actually
observed so those are the known known
values of our function corresponding to
the X's that we have
the X Stars here those are the points
that we want to make predictions at so
in in this case the X stars are
basically the entire x-axis domain we've
just very finally gone through and said
like we have 200 x stars in this in this
domain here okay and so those are the
the points that we want to predict our
function at
and then lastly the Y hats are the
actual predicted values that we're
making so the the darkest one is showing
the mean and then those those lighter
samples are are just showing different
samples from the distribution
okay so that's that's sort of breaking
it down and now we'll we'll we'll build
up what what we're actually talking
about here
so just like before we can sort of write
the joint distribution here where y hat
is the predicted uh the predicted values
and Y is the values we've actually seen
so far
so we have our mean function we can get
the mean at both the points that we've
observed and the points where we're
making predictions and then we're just
building this covariance Matrix which if
you think back to that initial slide on
gaussian uh on multivariate gaussians
these are just our a b and c matrices
that we're now using in our in our
gaussian process
okay so we can extend this now so this
is just the expression for our mean so
our our mean Vector here is just a
collection of the mean on the points
that we're looking at
and the The covariance Matrix we've
already seen here
okay so just like we had the gaussian
update equations this might look you
know a little intimidating you're like
whoa what's that all that is is the
gaussian update equations so that same
mu of a given B that we looked at it's
just it's that's all this is so we're
just looking at uh we want to make this
prediction the what we want to predict
at y hat given our y values that we've
already observed
and then we have just this is just from
the the gaussian update equations here
so this is the mean at the at the all of
the predicted values and then we're
looking at the covariance between the
points we want to predict at and the
points we've already seen and then the
the covariance between the points that
we've we've seen as well and an
important point to notice here is that
the covariance does not depend on the
actual values that you see so you can
see in the in the covariance term y does
not show up at all so your your
uncertainty regions around your your
gaussian process they don't depend on
what you've seen at all so that's that's
just an important point to keep in mind
it's only that spatial relationship of
where you have data and where you don't
have data that's being represented there
okay and so we we have some notebooks
that we'll see uh later of how you would
actually you know code this up and uh
implement it so
um we'll we'll get to the actual
implementation side as well of this
all right so this is just another sort
of visual example here of these are your
your uh fit points those are oops those
are the points that you've taken uh
measurements at and you've observed the
function and then you have your
predicted mean here using the the
gaussian update equations we just saw on
the previous slide
and the important point to notice here
is that the further that we get from our
data regions so where we've actually
observed these points the further we get
from that the larger our uncertainty is
so our uncertainty grows the further
away we get from the the data and this
is the nice feature about the gaussian
process is it sort of tells you hey
you're in a regime over here where you
don't have
where you don't have a lot of data so
you shouldn't be too confident in those
predictions so it's it's sort of that
flag of this is what I this is what I
think but you're not very certain about
this so you know don't go making any
life and death decisions based on this
prediction here whereas when you're
closer to the points you've seen so far
you have you have that lower uncertainty
there
okay and we also already saw we saw the
visual example but incorporating noisy
measurements is quite easy so in this in
this case we have perfect function uh
function evaluation so we're observing
it perfectly but in the real world
that's often not the case so if we want
to incorporate that uncertainty in our
in our measurements that we have it's
pretty straightforward by introducing so
this is the actual function f of x and
then we're adding some some random uh
noise onto that
and so if we want to include that now in
in uh the model that we're working with
here it's pretty straightforward the
only change we're making is adding in
this this new term here that's all
that's all that we've done we're just in
incorporating that uncertainty in in the
points that we've seen so far
and so just like before we can write the
gaussian update equations here and the
only thing that's changed is just just
adding that in there that's the that's
the only change that we have
okay
so it's it's very straightforward to
account for the noise
and if we want to just look at how this
changes it we already saw that initial
example
but now around the data points that we
have we still have some uncertainty
there
okay so it's it's allowing us to account
for that in our model
and if we if we want to compare that to
before
basically all you're seeing is that the
uncertainty is collapsed when we have no
noise and when we do have noise we just
we're still accounting for that as well
yeah
using this new professor yes yes so that
would be sort of you you would
characterize your sensor you would know
sort of how how uncertain am I in the
values that I'm getting and based on
that you would sort of put that into
your model and say this is the the
sensor uncertainty here
what we're showing here I believe is the
95 confidence bound so it's like the
whatever Z Star score that corresponds
to yeah
but yeah it can it can vary too
okay so we're working our way through
probabilistic surrogate models the
the next thing we're going to look at is
actually fitting the gaussian process so
we've got some data and now we want to
fit that data the best that we can
so I sort of already touched on on this
example with the the phone prices but
we'll dive into it a little bit more so
we have some
some data some historical data of phone
prices to sales that we have here
and we want to our boss comes to us and
says I want to uh I want to look at
changing the price of this phone and
there's three different three different
prices I'm considering changing the
price to and I want you to tell me
what's our our forecast for the new
sales that we're going to to get
so for this example like let's say just
for visualization purposes these are the
actual values that we would see we don't
know that though all we can see is the
Blue Points that's all we've observed so
far
and so if you hadn't taken this class
maybe you would just go to your boss and
say well I fit a line to this data and
here is what I think the uh the
prediction is and so maybe you get lucky
and your boss decides to go with you
know the far price on the left and
you're not that far off from your
prediction and you get a promotion
but maybe maybe you're unlucky and your
boss decides to go with the middle price
point and you're way off and your boss
is not happy with you at that point
so
basically we can we can often do better
than just the linear fit by by looking
at the maximum likelihood of of our data
so our goal here is we want to find the
parameters so we're going to
parameterize our gaussian process and so
if we want to think about what what is
the parameter here well for the squared
exponential kernel that's our length
scale
but you can even take that further and
you can say well the the kernel function
itself is the parameter so maybe you
have different kernel functions as your
parameters that starts getting a bit
complicated so for our example we'll
just talk about length scale is one of
our parameters here
okay so we want to we want to look at
the probability of our data that's our y
given the X's that we've seen and the
parameters of our model okay
so
what we're actually going to work with
is the log likelihood here
and so for with our with our gaussian
you can remember that we just have the
expression it's just this uh 2 pi
to the negative n over 2 and then we
have the
inverse or the negative one-half so the
square root of the determinant of our
Sigma
and then we have the the exponent term
here
okay and so if we want to take the log
probability of this all that is is just
taking the log so if we do that we take
the log of this expression we're just
going to end up with uh negative n over
two
and then similarly we're going to have
just the log determinant here and since
we're working with logs remember we can
just just add them up and then the log
here is going to cancel out and so we're
just left with
that term on the inside
okay so pretty pretty straightforward
for the for a gaussian distribution we
just got something some nice analytical
expression like that
the good news is that if we want to
extend this to the gaussian process we
get the exact same thing the only
difference that you see is that we've
introduced the uh the K of theta so
that's our our covariance Matrix now is
just instead of instead of Sigma all
Sigma is is just the the kernel function
parameterized by whatever our parameters
are in this case our length scale
and then plus that uh that uncertainty
term
similarly the only difference in our mu
is that it's we don't write it as Mu now
we're saying it's it's m Theta of X so
it's just a mean Vector based on the the
data points that we're we're looking at
so this is great news because we have
this analytical expression for this and
so that makes maximum likelihood
estimation really easy
so the good news we can fit the
parameters of the gaussian process using
maximum likelihood estimation okay and
so say say in this example we go and we
actually do that this is just these
aren't real values these are just you
know for for visualization maybe we go
and do that and we get a great looking
fit
um and we we do really well and our boss
is much happier with us than than our
linear uh regression estimate and on top
of that we can also tell our boss how
confident we are in our prediction based
on on the modeling assumptions that
we've made
okay so that's that's how we would go
about fitting the gaussian process
so just to to summarize the
probabilistic surrogate models that
we've seen so far
just all they are is just a distribution
over functions now we've just saw that
that example where we just scaled it up
they're just distributions over
functions
and we've seen that the choice of the
kernel that you're actually choosing
that has a pretty significant impact on
the uh the smoothness of the functions
and the types of functions that you're
getting
we also saw that we can we can
incorporate measurement noise it's
relatively straightforward to do that
and then lastly we can fit those
parameters using maximum likelihood
estimation yes
first one um can you represent other
types of noise besides additive using
aggression process or
application
yeah that's a good question
um
what what types of noise are you are you
thinking about there for example right
where you're like noise is dependent on
your particular
yeah I
I think you should be able to
yeah yeah you can't yeah you wouldn't be
able to just add it in like we did with
the new but it seems like that there
probably is a way to do that
um and then uh if you're trying to for
example extrapolate your fit rather than
trying to interpolate between values
do the kernel functions need to be kind
of bounded or some of them be unbounded
as you kind of get further and further
away from the points you've actually hit
yeah good question so
um in the example that we saw here
looking at the extrapolation so here
because we were just using uh the
squared exponential kernel with a zero
mean you sort of see that decay it's
just going back to zero because we're
saying our mean function is zero so as
we get further further and further away
you just Decay back but if you're using
a different mean function
um different kernel function I would say
still has some
impact but the main result you're seeing
here is due to the zero mean so if you
had some some different type of mean
function maybe you're looking at like
you're saying it's a linear based on the
points you've seen then yeah you could
be unbounded and you could just keep
increasing based on that uh that
relationship that you saw
yep
okay
so we're gonna transition now so we've
we've sort of seen how to uh how to
model with the the gaussian process now
we're going to transition from how to
model to how to sample right and that's
that's what our our optimization is sort
of focused on is selecting these these
sample points to to get our function
evaluations at
so we still want to keep this this high
level you know roadmap picture in mind
where we we have you know few samples at
the start and then we're we're choosing
our sample locations so that we better
learn what the function actually is that
we're interested in and so that's what
the surrogate optimization is focused on
is is how to sample the function
okay so the the first one that we're
gonna look at is prediction based
exploration and so if you think back to
quadratic fit search that's essentially
the same exact thing as uh prediction
based exploration so as a refresher in
quadratic fit search you're just looking
at the the three the last three
bracketing points and you're fitting a
Quadra quadratic function to those those
points
so that's kind of like your surrogate
model right you're just saying okay we
have a we have a quadratic surrogate
model and then we're going to take the
minimum of that quadratic function and
we're going to sample wherever that
minimum is
and that's all prediction based
exploration is doing the only difference
now is you're not using a quadratic
function you're using the mean the
predicted mean of your gaussian process
okay so it's the same exact thing it's
just your your model is no longer the
quadratic function okay so if we want to
look at look at this in detail
we're taking the sample at the minimum
of the predicted mean
so we can actually look at this through
through a real example here
so to to break this down the black
function just like we've been looking at
this black curve here is the true
function
the data that we've seen so far is this
this point here and there's another
Point here the red point is the point
that we're actually going to take the
sample at so there's there's a black
point it might be hard to see but
there's a black point underneath that
red point
the blue is the predicted mean from our
gaussian process
so we look at where is the minimum of
this predicted mean and in this case the
minimum is right about here so then we
say okay we're going to sample at that
point just like we did in quadratic fit
search
so we go and we sample there
so we take the sample we've now added it
there's two samples here it kind of
looks like one but there's two we update
based on the gaussian update equations
so we update our predicted mean
we see that the new predicted minimum is
now right about here so then we we say
okay we're going to sample there at that
red point
so we go and Sample at that point and
then we repeat and we update our our
gaussian process we get a new predicted
mean and then we we select another
sample location
and then it gets us pretty close to the
minimum so we can say okay great we're
done prediction based exploration close
the book we're good to go
the only issue with that is that
obviously this was a very nice this was
a very nice example to start out with so
you can imagine
and it's not very hard to come up with a
counter example of where this this
wouldn't work out too well okay so if
instead our function had looked
something like
this
right and so we had started over here
with these two points
and we had said that our predicted mean
looked something like this
you know something like that and then we
went through our sampling it would take
us you know to this local minimum
but then we've totally missed out on
this one over here since we were just
focused on what was going on over here
and we never even considered this part
over here okay so that's the issue with
prediction based exploration is that
often we we sort of just get stuck in
these local Minima and it's not really
doing any exploring of the space
the other thing to keep in mind is that
it's not taking uncertainty into account
at all so we just went through all this
work of making sure that our our
probabilistic surrogate model is
representing the uncertainty in our data
and now we're not even we're not even
using that so it's kind of a kind of a
waste like why did we even do that in
the first place it does take it into
account a little bit when we're actually
doing the the mean prediction so it's
there but we're not really using that in
our in our exploration
and then the other point is that the new
samples are often very close to the
existing samples so it's it's sort of a
waste of sampling there
all right so if we want to do a little
better
and maybe now we say okay well we didn't
do any exploration at all so let's let's
do some exploration here so error based
is looking at
where the standard deviation the
predicted standard deviation is the
greatest so we're choosing our samples
to maximize that uh that predicted
standard deviation
and so you can think about this because
the the larger the standard deviation is
the more the more uncertain we are in
the actual uh true function there so
we're sort of saying we want to become
more certain in our function and that's
that's sort of our our guide here for
this exploration
so if we look at again same exact
example here
we're going to start out and now we're
we're also visualizing the uncertainty
here so we start out and instead where
prediction base was just taking a sample
here this goes directly to the bounds of
this of the domain and so because our
uncertainty is greatest at the bounds we
just sort of clamp those down first
right away so we sample at the left
bound then we sample at the right bound
and then we sort of get into it of uh
actually going through through uh and it
so the the next highest uncertainty is
sort of on that left Peak there so we
sample there
and now we're sort of just like playing
whack-a-mole with the uncertainty right
so we we clamp one down and then another
another one pops up so we go and we
whack that mole and we're just sort of
continuing to play whack-a-mole here
with with error based exploration
and so we can just keep going through it
wherever the the uncertainty is the
highest sample at those locations and we
end up we we end up with a pretty good
you know understanding of what our
function looks like
and we've distributed our samples pretty
well throughout the the sampling process
the only issue here now is that often
the functions that we're interested in
are defined over very large domains
sometimes just all of RN right and so
they're they're unbounded functions and
in the case where they are unbounded you
saw what What error-based exploration
wanted to do it goes straight to the
bounds in this case we have bounded it
so we put the domains as only it can
only go between those so if you're
working with problems where you know the
bounds pretty well like say for the the
phone price example you know that your
your phone the the sales corresponding
the price the price has to be greater
than zero right and you're not going to
make it you know a million dollars for a
phone so that one we'd say is pretty
well bounded but in a lot of other
applications you don't have those bounds
on it and that's where where you run
into some issues with with error based
okay so it has to be constrained to that
that closed region yes
what was your problem is kind of high
dimensional would it try to go to all
the corners first I guess
yeah yeah so if you took it like into
many higher Dimensions where you're
looking at I don't like you have some
hyper Cube that you've bounded it to
you're going to go to because the error
is going to be greatest unless you
already have samples at those those
bounds so if you don't have samples
there that's where that's where you're
going to go and Sample at those those
bounds first
yes uh what is the relation between
Sigma hat and the kernel
the sigma hat and the kernel yes that's
a great uh great question so you can
back out Sigma hat so from your your
covariance Matrix
um if you look at the diagonal terms
those are uh those are essentially the
the variance at each of your points so
how much so you can think about the
diagonal here is basically what we're
showing here
the the only the only caveat is that
there's a square root in there because
we're going from variance to standard
deviation but yeah it's just the the uh
the diagonals
okay
so we've seen
error based we've seen prediction based
and we've seen some of the the drawbacks
to both of them
lower confidence bound is essentially
just taking a combination of both
so
if you recall what we just saw in
prediction based we're trying to
minimize the predicted mean and in error
base we're trying to sample at the
maximum of the standard deviation
so now lower confidence bound is just
combining those together and it does
that combination just through this
parameter Alpha so Alpha is sort of
controlling the weight that you're
giving to prediction base versus error
based okay and the minus sign here is
just keep that in mind because in
Airbase we were trying to take the
maximum of the standard deviation here
we're trying to minimize this lower
confidence bound so that's why we we get
that minus sign
and so this is just really sort of
focused on the it's a balance of the
exploitation exploration trade-off where
here prediction based is trying to
exploit the samples that we've already
seen so we already have samples in
specific regions prediction base is just
saying hey I already know like what's
going on here I can probably do better
if I sample closer to that and exploit
the knowledge that I already have
whereas the exploration side is the
error base where we're saying hey we
really don't know what's going on over
there let's go explore let's go find
that out and so you have that sort of
tug of war going on between the two and
your Alpha is the parameter that's
controlling controlling that how much
priority you're given to one versus the
other so when Alpha if you set Alpha to
zero then you're just going to be doing
all prediction based and if you said
Alpha to Infinity then you're going to
be doing all error based Alpha somewhere
in the middle you're going to be a
balance between the two and so Alpha
that's another parameter that you would
you would set for your specific uh
application
so we can look at how this actually
performs
so we see
we see here same exact example again and
just keep in mind that
we're trying to minimize the lower bound
so we're trying to sample where this
this red line is low so lower values are
good
and the other thing we want to see is
that
you can see the sort of balance here
when the predicted mean is high but we
have large uncertainty we still get a
good value for the the lower bound
similarly when we have these these lower
values here with no uncertainty we're
saying that basically it's it's only the
uh the predicted mean there okay
so we're just going to go through and
Sample wherever that that red line
wherever our lower confidence bound is
lowest
so we start off here
and I would say this is this is sort of
an exploration one but you know it's not
it's not exactly one is exploration one
is exploitation but then we go here and
this is definitely more of a of
exploiting what we already know because
we're predicting the mean to be pretty
low there and then we continue on and
the next one we get I would say this is
definitely more of an ex exploration
term okay so we sort of balancing that
here through through the alpha that
we've Chosen and we can continue on
and again we we end up with something
that looks pretty reasonable here
and by the end we get we get a
reasonable uh distribution of samples
and also a pretty good characterization
of our of our actual function
okay so now the only issue is that we'll
you still have the bounds issue right
because your your uncertainty is still
going to grow as you go to the the
bounds of the domain so you still have
that but you have a little bit more
control over that because if you if you
choose an alpha such that you're not
really caring as much about your
standard deviation you won't necessarily
always be going to those those bounds so
it sort of takes care of the problem but
it's it's still there okay
but it's just trying to take the best of
both of prediction based and error base
and combine them together
okay so now we're going to look at
probability of improvement
and I think this this one makes a lot of
intuitive sense for why we would want to
do it
and so let's get just sort of a picture
started here to work with
okay so let's say that our true function
looks something like this
and maybe we've sampled here
we've sampled here
and maybe we've sampled here so far
okay and then we've we've updated our
gaussian process we've gotten some new
uh predicted mean and maybe our mean
looks
something
like this
so now probability of improvement is
asking
at any point along here what's the
probability that I'm going to do better
than what I've seen so far
so the best that we've seen so far
remember we're trying to minimize so the
best we've seen so far is this point
right here
this is our y min
so we're asking everywhere along here
what's the probability that I'm going to
be below y min
so say for example we actually want to
look at this at one specific point so
let's say what's the probability of
improvement
right here at this x value
so we're going to come over here
and we're going to look we're going to
say okay at this point
so at this specific X
we're going to look at what is our what
is our predicted mean from our gaussian
process right now so that's right here
right we're saying we predict it right
there and remember we have a predicted
mean and a predicted variance or
standard deviation so with that we can
get a distribution right so if we just
draw that Distribution on here it's
going to look something like this
right so we've just we've just sort of
dropped the bell curve down there based
on whatever variance we currently have
at that point
all right so we have our mean we have
our standard deviation we want to know
what's the probability that we're going
to do better than this
so to see that we're just going to draw
across from here so we we want to do
better than this y Min value
right
and now I think it's pretty clear to see
well the probability that we're going to
do better than that y Min it's just this
tail of the distribution here
right so that's that's our probability
of improvement if we integrate this this
tail from negative Infinity up to this y
Min value that is the probability that
we're going to be doing better than what
we've seen so far
okay so any questions there we'll we'll
write out the actual math for this in a
second but any questions on the the
intuition side
okay
so what actually is the the Improvement
right
we can say that our Improvement
it's just however much better we're
doing than that why that y Min that
we've seen
so it's just going to be our y minus
whatever y we actually see so if we're
below it then we're going to be
improving if we're not below it we're
just gonna have zero so this is only if
Y is less than or equal to Y min
okay so that's our that's our
Improvement function
now we're interested in looking at the
probability of improvement right so we
want to know what's the probability that
we're doing better
than than this right now
and So based on our based on our picture
that we've drawn we can say the
probability
that Y is less than or equal to Y min
right that's just we're just integrating
up from negative Infinity all the way up
so we know that this is just this is
just the cumulative distribution
function here so we go from negative
Infinity to Y min
and it's just based on that gaussian
that we have
with our whatever our mu hat and
whatever our Sigma hat is
and we're just this is a y
we're just integrating that up so as as
I said this is just the the cumulative
distribution function which we can write
like this
and so this basically just converts it
to a a standard normal through that uh
that conversion there and we're just
looking at integrating up that tail yeah
oh sorry yeah that's uh why why Min is
the upper bound
yeah so the upper bound is just this
this y Min here
all right so yeah same picture that's up
here and if we want to look at how this
actually performs
so yeah I just have written we wanted
Max so we want to sample now at the
points where this probability of
improvement is the highest
so if we start off here you can see that
when
when we already have a sample right our
Sigma hat there is going to be zero so
this would be you know we would have a
divide by zero here which would be
undefined but we can sort of just say
well we know we're not going to improve
if we sample there again because we
already know what the function value is
so the Improvement there is just zero so
that's why we have these spikes here
where it just drops down
but then what you see is right around
those those points that we already have
we have a that's where the highest
probability of improvement is is Right
very close to where we've already
sampled so we go ahead and we sample at
where the probability of improvement is
high now we have two samples there we've
also we have technically improved our
function we got a lower value
and so now our problem our probability
of improvement is really high right
because now we have very little
uncertainty there we sort of have that
predicted mean is decreasing so we're
saying let's keep sampling there right
we've seen that we're doing good so
we're going to keep on sampling there
and we just kind of keep going down
along that route
so I think this is a little
disappointing to see because it's a
really nice setup right it makes sense
you're looking at the tail you're kind
of talking about what's the probability
we're going to do better than this but
then in practice what we actually see is
that often we end up very similar to
prediction based where we're sampling
very close to the samples that we've
already seen so that's kind of a bummer
and just like we said it tends to it
tends to actually do the job right it is
decreasing the objective but we're doing
it one in that just local area so we
could be susceptible to the local Minima
and two it's it's sort of wasting our
our samples again
so I think the the natural extension of
this would be not just looking at what's
uh the probability of improvement but
what we what do we actually expect that
Improvement to be right because
probability of improvement was just
saying whatever wherever the probability
is highest let's go there expected
Improvement is now saying let's look at
not just the probability that we're
going to improve but how much do we
actually think we're going to improve by
so if we want to to look at this now
we're going to just start off by doing a
very just simple change of variables and
it'll be clear why we why we're doing
this in a second but we're going to
introduce this Z variable and we're
going to say that that Z is just equal
to Y minus mu hat
over our Sigma hat
and we're going to say y Min Prime here
is equal to our y min
minus our mu hat
over Sigma hat so we're just converting
it to to standard standard normal that's
why we're doing this change of variables
and you'll see it'll it'll make some
some stuff work out nicer here
so we do this change of variables and
now we want to rewrite our our
Improvement function
that I think I've covered up here so our
our Improvement function now with this
change of variables
is just going to be Sigma hat
times y Min Prime
minus Z
and this is if our uh
this is if Z is less than or equal to
our y Min Prime
and it's zero otherwise so all we've
done here is we just took what we had
before was y Min minus y we've now just
subbed in our change of variables here
to get us this new Improvement function
okay so now now we're interested in the
expected value of this Improvement
function
so if we looked at the expected value
if we if we take the expectation
remember it's just the we're just
integrating over the probability
distribution where we take the expected
value of the function times the
probability that's all expected value is
is just value times the probability of
that value
so the function value here is just this
this Improvement so it's just this term
we don't care about when it's zero
because we know that'll just be zero
so we're going to have Sigma hat on the
outside here because it it's constant
and our bounds of integration again are
from same same as before negative
Infinity up to Y min
but here we've introduced the change of
variables so it's y Min Prime now
okay and then we're just going to bring
this in so y Min Prime
minus our Z
so that's our function value
and then our function uh or the
probability of this right is just
now we now we see it's just the standard
normal right because we made that change
of variables so that's why we did it so
this is just the expect it's this is all
it is is the expected Improvement here
that we've written
all right and so there's not much that
we can do with it in this form right
because we have this integral here so we
want to we want to simplify this a
little bit
so
to simplify this we're just going to
break up break up that integral so the
first term we're going to have our Sigma
hat is going to be on the outside now
and we're just going to write write that
first term
so our y Min Prime doesn't depend on our
our Z here so we can bring that out of
the integration
and we're just going from negative
Infinity to Y Min Prime
and it's just going to be
uh our distribution for Z here
okay so that term that's good because we
know this is exactly what we saw before
this is just the probability of
improvement for Z so that term is almost
already taken care of will simplify it
in the next step but this is we're
looking good here
then we're just going to bring in this
this other term so we're going to have
the minus here
and we're going to go negative Infinity
y Min Prime again
of Z
and then the standard normal
here okay
so
we know that this is just the expected
value of Z right because we have value
times probability so that's our expected
value of Z and we know because it's the
standard normal if we were going from
negative Infinity to positive Infinity
it would just be zero right because it's
just the expected value of a standard
normal gaussian and that's zero because
that's our our mean
in this case we're not going from
negative Infinity to positive Infinity
we're going from negative Infinity to Y
Min Prime
and so what this ends up actually
working out to is we have this nice
result result for uh for gaussians where
it comes out to being this term would
just be uh our y Min Prime
given our mean and standard deviation
and then it's going to be minus the uh
the other bounds of integration which is
at negative Infinity
okay where we know here
the likelihood at negative Infinity is
just zero because there's no there's no
uh there's no tail there right as we go
to Infinity so we can just get rid of
this
that's just zero
and if you're curious on how we got from
this step to this step what if you
actually want to work it out you'd have
to introduce the actual expression here
for the gaussian and then it's just you
know a couple of lines to get from there
to here but we know this nice result
that we can work with for gaussians
where we can just take the tail here of
uh of the bounds of integration and sub
it in so that's all I've done
for those two steps
so now we're ready to simplify this
right we just have this term and this
term
so if we will simplify it and get our
final expression here
so the uh the what we actually come out
to now is we're going to have uh this
Sigma hat still multiplying everything
and then we're going to have the Y Min
Prime
times the probability that Z is less
than or equal to Y Min Prime
and then we have just this term here
okay and now if we want to sub back in
and uh reverse our change of variables
here to get our final result we can go
ahead and do that and what we're going
to end up with is y min
us y
minus our mu our mu hat
and that's going to be times this
probability where it's now probability
that Y is less than or equal to Y min
and then this term is just going to
become
Sigma hat squared and then we're going
to have
uh this this will be y min
and our distribution is now with respect
to Mu hat and sigma hat
okay and so this is the final expression
for our expected Improvement that we've
now switched it back to
okay so that was sort of how we how we
get to this result
and so now this is nice because we have
our probability of improvement there we
have how much we're sort of expecting to
improve this by and the likelihood here
and then we've also we've included sort
of that that
distribution term there for our
uncertainty okay so now we can actually
implement this and see how we perform on
this expected Improvement
metric
and so this is just the these are the
steps that I just went through here
and I didn't make any typos so that's
good
okay so now if we actually
implement this
um we're seeing the exact uh same
example as before where our expected
Improvement is shown on the bottom so we
start off and we're going to sample
actually very close to the minimum so I
think this is just more of a nice
example here that we start off doing
that it won't always be the case then we
go we go to the bounds next
and we sort of clamp those down so you
can still see we have that that
dependence on the bounded region
and then lastly we end up we end up
sampling there so it definitely does
better than probability of improvement
right and and now it's it's sort of I
think intuitively makes sense that
you're looking at not just what's the
likelihood I'll improve but how much do
I actually expect to improve by so I
think it makes a lot of sense there on
on why you would uh want to use this
this type of method
okay so this is just sort of the main
point we're just looking at where we
expected to improve it as much as
possible
and so if we want to look at a really
quick comparison of expected Improvement
versus probability of improvement for
this specific example we can compare the
two so on the left we have probability
of improvement on the right we have
expected Improvement
and so if we go ahead and we sample at
the maximum of both of those we can sort
of see how they how how they would
differ
so if we actually look at where they
would sample the probability of
improvement like we saw before is
sampling very close to where we've
already seen whereas expected
Improvement is doing a little bit better
and going to to Regions that we haven't
yet seen
Okay so we've seen that we can use the
probabilistic surrogate model the
gaussian process to sort of guide where
we're going to place our samples and uh
important thing to keep in mind is all
of the strategies that we've talked
about here they're just looking at the
next sample location okay they're not
taking into account a sequence of
samples and so that would involve some
some sequential sequential decision
making which is sort of what uh my
research is focused on is how do you use
these surrogate models to then look at
placing a sequence of samples not just
that that next sample
okay so that's the uh that's the
overview of everything we've talked
about we have
two minutes left here so really quickly
uh this notebook will be posted but I
just wanted to give you a brief overview
of the structure of it
um and then you can you can play around
with it on your own
uh but basically this just implements
everything that we looked at today
and so there's this uh there's this GP
file here that has a lot of the
structure behind it and some of the
helper functions that are being used but
I'm just going to highlight the the main
the main part that you need to get
started so this uh structure here is
just all we need to specify our gaussian
process and this is all in Julia a real
programming language
so so all we need is just that mean
we're doing zero mean uh we have our
squared exponential kernel here and then
these are just the data points that
we've seen so far or wise and then the
new term and here we're saying we have
uh perfectly observable measurements
I'll I'll wrap this up quickly so we can
just this is just implementing this what
might have seemed scary to you at first
it's not scary at all we can just
implement it in these few lines here of
doing this prediction so we're just
putting these equations into code
and uh then we can actually go ahead and
run it so I'll just highlight some of
the examples so we can just sample like
different functions that we saw before
we can do it in two Dimensions as well
and then we can actually uh look at some
some of the different exploration
strategies so if we're doing prediction
based this will actually like walk you
through each one of those and you can
see how the samples would change based
on what uh what your function looks like
so you can go ahead play around with
that we've implemented it for all of
them so for expected Improvement
everything you can go take a look at
that and uh I'm happy to to answer any
questions that you would have as well
thank you